government forces fleeing Ramadi a vivid
illustration of what may be a failing
strategy to deal with the so-called
Islamic state its forces are close to
the gates of Baghdad and America's n boy
to the coalition as a diplomat's take on
a military problem we learned a lot from
Ramadi and it's important that we
understand the lessons that came out of
that particular fight and that we seek
to apply the lessons learned to the
implementation of the strategy and what
were those lessons it's important i
think is a lesson in contrast if you
look at the Euphrates that ground is
under the control of the Iraqis and the
tribes and the elements that have come
out of Assad Ramadi on the other hand
was a group of Iraqi fighters that had
been fighting for 18 months there
they've been under nearly constant
pressure by dash had held out for a long
period of time there are some who have
compared this to the fall of Mosul this
is not the fall of Mosul these folks
have been fighting hard for 18 months to
hold on to that capital in the end there
was a surge of dosh activity to include
attacking several of the points around
the perimeter where the Iraqi forces
were distributed with some pretty
significant suicide V beds vehicle-borne
IEDs and these were measured in the
thousands of pounds of yield but surely
with 18 months I mean yes the Coalition
is young but it battle from Ramadi is
not new as you say they were holding out
for 18 months it must have been obvious
to the experts from the United States of
America and others that these guides are
being hung out to dry well hung out to
dry i think is what i had no logistics
they ran out of ammunition and they'd
low on food silly miles from bank that
and i think we need to be careful about
whether they were intentionally hung out
to dry or whether the Iraqis needed the
capacity or two for us potentially the
system and building the capacity is
Lamech state strategy is clear its
consolidated its control over
important cities like Ramadi in Iraq and
Palmyra in Syria the aim to establish
bridgeheads to threaten the two capitals
and it's establishing political power
through terror spreading its influence
beyond the areas it directly controls
and now it's got what looks like a clear
run towards Jordan and Saudi Arabia
Islamic state is consolidating its hold
over a bigger and bigger territory again
I would I would contend that saying
that's not going well for the coalition
just isn't correct we do have setbacks
in Ramadi is definitely a setback there
are elements of Iraqi security forces
that are approaching Ramadi now so it's
again it's not like Mosul where it
collapsed and it has remained in dashas
hands now for well over a year the
Iraqis are going to take Ramadi back
this was the catch-22 wasn't it you had
an Islamic state advance on Assad
territory which the coalition was not
prepared to protect because you would
have been providing air support to the
Assad regime the key point here is is
not that we did not take action because
it was a regime issue and I think we
you'll find that we have the capacity
and probably the intent to take action
if Josh continues both to move either to
the west or to the east towards a loud
bar towards our ally Jordan or Saudi
Arabia but there is a different
operational environment in Iraq than
there is in Syria in Iraq we have a
partner but within the coalition there
is friction over why Islamic state is
attacked but the Assad regime has been
left untouched Syria is a different case
because we don't have the kinds of
partnerships right now that we need all
admit you don't know there isn't a
strategy for Syria is there your syringe
the skin you can you explain to me what
their strategy from the coalition's
perspective of Washington's perspective
is to do not just about Islamic state
but about the Assad regime the strategy
of the Coalition is to deal with dash
the policy ultimately is to deal with
Bashar al-assad and that is not a
strategy that is not a component of the
strategy with respect to dash
but the subtlety of that distinction is
going to be lost on America's most
important regional allies Qatar Turkey
and Saudi Arabia to them fighting
Islamic state is almost secondary to
ending acids reign of terror Sam Kiely
Sky News Washington